[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انها الساعه 60 برنامج
اخباريون خاص ومتنوع و بايقاع سريعا
ومختلف جدا نحلل الاحداث بابعادها وبعمق
وبين العاجل والمهم نضع الاهم وسوره
الكامله البدايه من العناوين
سلاح الطاقه
من اجل الحلول
قائد والعمليات الروسيه الجديد امام بنات
افكاره النظرياته انتجت بادمر والان عليه
مواجهتها فلمن النصر
وفي ملفات الساعه60 التضخم تهديد قد يلازم
العالم لسنوات اعاده فتح اقتصاد الصين قد
تزيد منه فكيف تتاثر انت
وتهديد اخر متجددا داعش قد يعود من سوريا
والعراق مرورا بافريقيا ووصولا الى
افغانستان امريكا تتاهل
[موسيقى]
على مداريه اشهر ظل سلاح الطاقه احد اوجه
الصراع بين روسيا والغرب الاوروبيون
سيتجمدون اذا التزم الغرب بعقوبات الطاقه
التي فرضها ضدنا بهذه الكلمات توعد الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتن دول اوروبا في
سبتمبر الماضي انتصف الشتاء الان تقريبا
فماذا عن النتيجه يبدو انها تشير الان الى
واحد لاوروبا صفر لروسيا وذلك بحسب تعبير
احد وزراء الطاقه الاوروبيين نيبوليتيكو
الاسباب كثيره بها لاحقا التحول للغاز
المسال كان احدها وكانت النتيجه زياده
الوارده من ثلاثه
مليار متر مكعب في 2021 الى 2011 واربعين
مترا مكعبا في
2022 اي تعويض ثلاثه اربعه الثمانين مليار
متر مكعب التي لم تعد تلقاها اوروبا من
خطوط الانابيب الروسيه وتاكيدا لهذه
الارقام وزيرو ماليه احدى الدول كانت من
بين الاكثر تاثرا لانها كانت من بين
الاكثر اعتمادا على الطاقه الروسيه
المانيا وزرها خرج واكد لم نعد الان نعتمد
على روسيا في الطاقه كلام هنا صادقت عليه
رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه خلال منتدى لابس
الاقتصاديه اعلانات انا بروكسيل النجاح
حتى في التقليص الطلب على طاقه الروسيه
باكثر من 20% خلال الفتره من اغسطس وحتى
نوفمبر من العام الماضي
ويغفر افكار
شركه الروس اتم لطاقه النوويه قد تكون
مستهدفه بالعقوبات الجديده بحسب وثائق
نشرتها واشنطن بوست الشركه تعمل على امداد
صناعه الاسلحه الروسيه بالمكونات
التكنولوجيا المواد الخام لوقود الصواريخ
وهذه الشركه تحديدا افلتت من العقوبات
الجزئيه فهناك 18 محطه نوويه روسيه
التصميم تعمل في الاتحاد الاوروبي
وبالتالي ساعدت دول اوروبيه كبريطانيا
وفرنسا في التحول للوقود النووي بدلا من
الوقود الاحفوري محطه الطاقه النوويه
البلغاريه مثلا ما تنتج خمسه وثلاثين في
المئه من كهرباء البلاد عبر استخدام
الوقود النوويه الذي توفره
حتى امريكان نفسها تعتمد على الشركه
الروسيه في حوالي ربع امداداتها من
اليورانيوم المخصصه نعم انتهى اسوا ما في
ازمه الطاقه الاوروبيه لكن الشتاء القادم
قد يكون اصعب والعهده هنا على شركه ابحاث
الطاقه
[موسيقى]
بفضل يتغير المناخ كان شتاء و 2023 رحيما
حتى الان بالاوروبيين وكانه خذل موسكو
دافئا كما ذكرنا بالامس دفئ اضعف قوه احد
اقوى الاسلحه الروسيه الطاقه وقف الحظ مع
اوروبا في لعبه المناخ والطاقه العام
المنصرم كان ثاني اكثر الاعوام حراره على
الاطلاق في اوروبا اما اسيا فاشهدت انخفاض
استهلاك الغاز الطبيعيه امر ما اقل الطلب
وبالتالي استطاعت اوروبا ملى خزانات
الوقود لديها لكن الحظ وقته لا يكفي
اوروبا كانت لديها خطه رافقت الشتاء الذي
جاء فيني الاتحاد الاوروبي اوقف استيراد
الفحم والنفط الخام من روسيا دول مثل
فرنسا وهولندا وايطاليا عادت اليه تشغيل
محطات الفحم المتوقفه واليوم جاءت امدادات
الانقاذ من النرويج كما تتفاوضت الدول
الاوروبيه على عقود طويله الاجل للغاز
المسال وصلت اوله شحنه بالفعل من واشنطن
لي برلين التي دشنت ثلاث محطات تخزين
جديده هذا الشتاء يتوقع ان تغطي ثلث
تحتياجاتها السابقه
الاتحاد الاوروبي لم يكتفي بالهروب من فخ
الطاقه
الروسي قد يؤثر الامر اقتصاديا على موسكو
عندما تدخل قيود الغرب على صادرات ان يقتل
روسي حيز التنفيذ في فبراير الشهر المقبل
يتوقع ان تنخفض الامدادات الروسيه من
المنتجات البتروليه بنسبه 50 الى 60%
الطاقه سلاح موسكو الذي باتم وجها ضدها
اليوم على الاقل ولناخذ مثالا بسيطا
روسناف عملاق الطاقه الروسيه كانت تمتلك
نحو 20% من اجمالي مصافي المانيا قبل ان
تاممها برلين لكن جاسترو عملاق روسيون اخر
تعرض سرعه الالماني للتامين لتجنب برلين
خطر الانهيار الاقتصادي الكامل
بوظه الاغلاقات الجماعيه للمصانع في
المانيا وتانين الغازي والكهرباء عن
المنازل الذي كانت تخشى منه الحكومه
الالمانيه لم يحصل خزانات الغاز هنا
مازالت مليئه رغم ان الغاز الروسي لم يعد
يصل منذ اشهر طويله فالحكومه الالمانيه
نجحت باستبدال الغاز الروسي بغاز من
النرويج والولايات المتحده والجزائر من
بين دول اخرى و نجحت ايضا بافتتاح اول
خزان عائم للغاز المسال في البلاد بسرعه
قياسيه قبل نهايه العام الشتاء الدافئ
نسبيا ساعد على استخدام كميات اقل من
الغاز والمساعدات التي قدمتها الحكومه
ساعدت كذلك على تهدئه مخاوف المواطنين
والشركات من فواتير باهظه ومن بين هذه
المساعدات وضعوا سقفا لاسعار الغاز
والكهرباء ومساعدات ماليه نقديه قدمت
لشركات
افرض هذه الخطوات السريعه وان كانت باهظه
التي اتخذتها المانيا ساعدتها على التعايش
سريعا من دون الغاز الروسي على الاقل في
هذا الشتاء
مع صادرات الاسلحه تمثل الصادرات الطاقه
الروسيه مفتاحا مهما استخدمتهم موسكو قبل
الحرب بيشركاء وحلفاء جدد والابتعاد عن
الغرب حتى ان اعتماد اوروبا على موارد
الطاقه الروسيه يرجع الى ما قبل بوتن
وتحديدا الى الحرب البارده في عام
1972 حوالي 4% من استهلاك الغاز الاوروبي
كانت تاتي من الاتحاد الصوفيه
السوفيات كانوا لا يستخدمون الطاقه
السلاحا لكن رؤيه كانت مختلفه كانت اصلا
محورتها اطروحته للدكتوراه في
1997 وقت ما كان نائبا لرئيسه بلديه سان
بيترسبر الطاقه لا ينبغي ان تكون مجالا
مستقلا تماما وهكذا جاد لا توتا في
اطروحته مؤكدا انه يجب ان تكون مرتبطه
بالدوله
وفي عميه 2000 تولى بوتن الرئاسه وبدا
وقتها التطبيق العملي لاطروحته تدريجيا
خلق اعتمادا غربيا على مصادر الطاقه
الروسيه وبحلول عام 2021 كانت روسيا توفر
ما يقرب من 40% من غاز اوروبا
ابهر بوتن استعدادا لممارسه الضغط في
الوقت المناسب على اوروبا ودمج الاقتصاد
والسياسه والوقت حالا خلال حرب اوكرانيا
يستمر الرئيس الروسي في استخدامه ذهبت
الحصص الاضافيه الى الصين والهند وتركيا
وباكستان وتخفيضات كبيره كما منع
كازاخستان من تصدير النفطها الذي يمر 90%
منه عبر اراضي موسكو السبب رئيسها قاسم
التوكيف
لم قرر عدم الاعتراف بدنيتك ولوز ولكن
اتصالح بعدها بالمناسبات في العموم قللت
ااا من ما يقرب اذا لنذهب الى
النقطه الثانيه ما يقرب من التريليون
دولار فاتوره اضطره اوروبا على دفعها
لتخلي عن اعتمادها على الطاقه الروسيه
مبلغ ضخم وقابل للزياده كل هذه الاموال
التي صرفت كان يمكن لاوروبا ان تستثمرها
في امور اخرى كان بامكان التكاثر الاوروبي
استثمار 400 مليار دولار للرضي على قانوني
خفض التضخم الامريكي الذي يمنح مثلا اعفاء
الضريبيه للمكونات المستخدمه في تقنيات
الطاقه المتجدده مثل السيارات الكهربائيه
بشرط ان تكون مصنوعه في امريكا الشماليه
الرقائق الالكترونيه قصه اخرى اليوم تبلغ
حصه واعمل انتاجي الرقائق 8% انخفاضا من
24% عام 2000 وفي فبراير 2022
استثمرت بروكسل 43 مليار يورو لتطوير قطاع
رقائق ذكيه في دول الاتحاد الاوروبي
ومنافسه العمالقه كوشنطن بكين وتايوان
استثمار كان من الممكن ان يكون اكبر بكثير
لزياده حظوظ بروكسل التنافسيه في صناعه
الرقائق العالميه بما تمثله من اهميه
قطاعات عده هناك دول اوروبيه ضمن قائمه
الحكومات الاعلى ديوننا في العام خلال
2020 فرنسا بقيمه ثلاثه ريليونان و300
مليار دولار ايطاليا بقيمه ثلاثه ريونات
ومئه مليار ثم مثلها تقريبا المانيا بقيمه
ثلاثه ريونات دولار اذا تريليون دولار كان
من الممكن انا تساهم في خفض عبء الدين على
ايا من الدول الثلاث او كلها بالتساوي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
والمتابعه هذا الملف ينضم الينا من عمان
عامر الشوبكي الباحث في شؤون النفط
والطاقه اهلا بك هل فشل ريحان على طاقه ام
ان الهدف اصبح ابعد بقليل ليس اكثر هل
ستتدارك اوروبا
لترتب اوراق الطاقه لديها بعيدا عن
الاعتماد على روسيا
تحيه حنين نستطيع ان نقول بان اوروبا
بالفعل قفزت عن الكارثه الا انها ما زالت
موجوده لازمه الطاقه ما زالت موجوده
وتعاني منها الخسائر الموجوده على
القطاعات الاقتصاديه فواتير المواطنين ما
زالت مرتفعه اسعار الطاقه رغم انخفاض
اسعار الغازي الى قرابه 17$ للمليون وحده
حراريه بريطانيه الا انها ما زالت ضعف
الاسعار الطبيعيه الا انها ايضا اقل من 70
دولار وصلت اليها في الاشهر الماضيه لكن
اوروبا ما زالت الازمه خروجها فقط الان هو
بثمن بثمن كلف اوروبا اكثر من التريليون
دولار كل في اوروبا تعطيل 20% من
الاستهلاك من الطاقه الى الغاز وايضا
الاعتماد على الفحم يعني مرتفع الانبعاثات
الكربونيه وبالاضافه ايضا الى المخزونات
الموجودات حاليا
عن الفحم والذهب اكثر باتجاه يعني استخدام
همم صديق للبيئه بشكل اكبر للطاقه اذا
تجنبت الانهيار الكلي بحسب وزير الاقتصاد
الالماني يتحدث ان ان المانيا واوروبا
بشكل كامل بشكل عام تجنبت هذا الانهيار
لكن نعلم ان المشكله لن تكون فقط في عام
2023 فما هي الخطط التي لدى اوروبا
لتسلكها لتجنب والبناء همم خطه اشمل واوسع
همم تحمي الطاقه تحمي احتياجات الطاقه
لديها
بدايه عوده اوروبا الى الفحم هو امر
مفارقه طريفه يعني الان جميع في العالم
يتحدث عن التخلص من الانبعاثات الكربونيه
خاصه الفحم واوروبا تعود فهذه مفارقه لكن
الان ما هو متوفر امامه اوروبا فعلته في
الماضي سواء في بناء محطات الاستقبال
الغاز المسال كما حدث في المانيا وعده دول
تقليص الاستهلاك كم سيدوم هذا الامر سيكون
اصعب في الشتاء القادم كان متوفرا الغاز
عبر الاردن في العام 20 22 لاوروبا قبل
انقطاعه هذا ساعد على ملئ المخزونات الغاز
الروسيه الان يتدفق الى اوروبا ايضا بنسبه
سبعه ونص بالمئه بنحتاجات احتياجاتها
وبالتالي هذه النسبه ما زالت ايضا ضروريه
لمنع المخصومات مره اخرى اعتقد انه من
الصعوبه من المخزونات مره اخرى من فقط
الغاز المسال اذا ما افترضنا ايضا بانه من
الصعب جدا ان تتحمل والاقتصاد الاوروبي
الاسعار المرتفعه للطاقه التي ستبقى
مرافقه لاوروبا في العام الحالي حتى عند
مستوياتها الحاليه سيؤمن التنافسيه اقل
البضائع الاوروبيه وربما استمرار اغلاق
بعض الصناعات الكثيفه استخدام للغاز للغاز
مثل صناعه الصلب والاسمده وكانت هذه
ضروريه القاره الاوروبيه في الماضي عدا
فواتير الطاقه التي من المتوقع ان تبقى
ايضا مرتفعه
ايضا داخل بالمواطنين الاوروبيين ونشهد
اثر ذلك في احتجاجات واضطرابات داخل
اوروبا اشكرك على جزيره معنا من عمان عامر
الشوبكي الباحث في شؤون عنها
انتم زملاؤنا باك نانا للبيت الابيض في
الساعه بعد دقيقه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد يبدو ان النجاح الاخيره
التي حققتها مجموعه
الغربيه التي باتت مطالبه ايقافها
الولايات المتحده ستصنف منظمه اجراميه
عابره للحدود وستفرض عليها عقوبات الاسبوع
المقبل وهذا مؤكده البيت الابيض
دوليه فانتم الزملاءنا لكن ثم امرا اخر
اشار اليه البيت الابيض
السؤال الان ما هي حقيقه التصريحات
الامريكيه حول هذا التوتر بالاقتراب من
عام على الحرب افلا نجم الكثير من من
تسيدوا المشهد في روسيا ظل في الصوره
وجهاني بارزان يتصارعن على كسب والدفوتا
قائد باك ماريا بروجين وقائد والعمليه
الجديد جراسيمون الخلاف الحالي بينهما
قصته تعود للسنوات والبدايه كانت في
فبراير
2013 قائد الاركان الجديد وقتها اجراسيمون
يلقي محاضره عن اسس الحرب الهجينه نظريته
تعارض عقيده الجيش استوحاها من كتاب
الفيلسوف تولوي النظريه تقوم على مبدا
واحد على اربعه مين معنا اي عمليات عسكريه
تمثل ربع الاستراتيجيه ضد الخصم والبقيه
هي تطوير الاسلحه السيبرانيه تمويل
المعارضه الضغط الاقتصاديه على الدوله غير
الصديقات كما يسميها لكن بالتركيز على جزء
العمليات العسكريه فالنظريه تتضمن فكره
انضمام شركات خاصه للقت معالجيش هذه
النظريه اوجدت فاجنر الا ان قرارا خارج
علىها تخرج عن السيطره عن سيطره راسموحه
تحديدا الاخير اقر في 2014 اصلاحات هي
هيكليه افقدت الجيش نصف ضباطيه واكثر من
80% من ضباط الصف الذين رفضوا تجديد
عقودهم ذهب اغلبهم للتقاعد ليس كلهم هنا
كان بروكسجين في الانتظار وقتها رجل اعمال
بسجل اجراميه دون خبره عسكريه اسس فاجنر
في 2015 فاتحا الباب امام المنبوذين من
الجيش وحتى المساجين رواتب مغريه والحريه
مقابله السته اشهر من الخدمه
على الجبهه
[موسيقى]
يوم كويس
عاوزين ميه هناك
سبب مواطننا روس في سوريا عام 2018
الخلافه برزا الى السطح عندما فاشله في
الفوز بعقودا حصريا لتموين الجيش منذ 2018
الجيش الروسي ايضا دفع البرلمان قبل شهرين
الى طريق قانون ينظم عمل الشركات الخاصه
للرجيم رفض الخطوه وتسائل عن الهدف من
اصلاح كيانا يعمل بكفاءه وان بالقتل
المتسلسليه
[موسيقى]
جمانه
ياسر
[موسيقى]
القوات الروسيه فجرت عن طريق الخطا دبابه
خبر نقلته الصحيفه روسيه بين مهاجمه عناصر
فاجنرغيلازموفا بالاسم اتهموه بتفضيله
وحداتي الجيش اثناء توزيع الذخيره بينما
يقاتلون وحدهم من اجل باخوط القتال فيه
بخموط واسالدار غير من شكل بروكسيل في
عيون الروس دعايه ايجابيه كما تحدث البيت
الابيض لما يعد مجرد اخر تعتبر علاقته
بفوتنا السره نجاحه الوحيد وتحت صدى شعبيه
اعترف الكريمه بانجازات ذات نهار ووصفها
بالبطوليه خبره القاده وولاء الجنود
لفاكنر التي منحتهم فرصه ثانيه للحياه لم
يكن وحدهما السبب فبروجين لديه روايته
الخاصه وبغض النظر عن المستقيمتها كانت
تبدو على انها احصاء لانقاط ضعف الجيش
الروسيه الذي لم يتاقلم مع ظروف الحرب
الجيش
تناور بشكل اكبر ودائم ولا تستقر طويلا في
مكان واحد ولا وجود لكلمه قاعده في قاموس
باجنر سبب تكتكيا اخر جاء على لسان احد
مقاتلها
لا نقتحم المدن بهدف السيطره عليها في
البدايه نعمل على التطبيق المدينه وقطع
خطوط الامداد والاتصال فقد عندما يصبح
مركز المدينه تحت مرمى مدفعيتنا نقتحم
شوارعها
مسؤوليه الجيش الروسي في اداره الحرب في
اوكرانيا وصفا يفتقرون للدقه في الحقيقه
موسكو تشرف على العمليات القتاليه عبر
تحالفا للجيوش الموليه لها وبرنر اشهرها
لكنها اقلها عددا فماذا عن البقيه البدايه
من القوات الانفصاليه تقود الحرب
القرمه شهر ابريل عام 2014 بلغ تعداد
قوتها 50,000 مقاتل وميستها انها تحارب
على ارضها تنفذ المهام الاصعب على الارض
وتكبدات حصه الاسد من الخسائر البشريه تم
حلها نظريا بعد ضم روسيا للاقليم وهي الان
الجيش منفصل تابعا اليه وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه المشهد هو الميدانيه
عباره عن اتحاد فرق عسكريه منفصله القياده
بصيت مثلا مجموعه من النازيين الجدد في
روسيا علاقتها بفاكنر اقوى من انفصالي دوم
بس تتخذوا من جبهه خاركيف المسرحا
لعملياتها في حين تلاحقها تهم جرائم حرب
بحق السجناء الاوكرانيين جيش اخر اقرب
لوزاره الدفاع الروسيه وهي القوات الخاصه
الشيشانيه ولائهم قبل الطبعه المطلق
للرئيس رمضان قديروف لكن ذلك لم يمنع
تعاونهم مع الجيش بلغت عددهم في اوكرانيا
واحده وعشرين الفا 9000 منهم على الجبهه
تحديدا في الجروبكا شمال
ده تعداده عناصرها مؤخرا الى بضعه الاف
الى ع من قطعه الاف الى 10% من تعداد
القوات الروسيه في اوكرانيا هدفهم هو
السيطره الكامله على دوم بس بما في ذلك
رمث
صراع بين مختلف هياكل القوى الروسيه بعد
على الساحه الان في العمليه العسكريه
الروسيه وبحسب خبر عسكريين صراع خفيف قد
يكون بين قائد فاذر من جهه ووزاره الدفاع
الروسيه من جهه اخرى
استحوذ على الاضواء بظهوره المتكرر
وبمشاركه فاكتر اكثر في الحرب وتحديدا في
بخمض وسوليدار اما قائد العمليات العسكريه
الجديد دراسه موف لديه استراتيجيه جديده
على الارض اولا تسريعه عمليه اتخاذ القرار
العسكري لان الظروف كان لم يتمكن من اصدار
اوامر مباشره للاسطول او للطيران بعيد
المدى ثانيا امكانيه استخدامه من مجموعه
واسعه من الاسلحه المختلفه لضرب القوات
الاوكرانيه ومن بينها الاسلحه النوويه
مين ده بص حيث عقد المنتدى الاقتصادي
العالمي قالها الامين العام للامم المتحده
معطيات ومؤشرات العام الحالي تبدو كسابقه
لتكون المهمه الاساسيه التي اجمع عليها
الكل في 2003
هي تجنب السيناريو الاسود وطبعا لكل ازمه
اقتصاديه اسباب لكن اساس الوضع الحالي هو
التضخم او ما تعرفوا بطريقه الفقراء ظاهره
اددت الى اكبر تجديدا للسياسه النقديه منذ
عقود وقت لازم العالم لسنوات
وعادلته التضخم غير المسبوقه اثرت علينا
تاكله القدره الشرائيه للمستهين سبعون
مليون شخص نزلوا تحت خط الفقر بسبب التضخم
ووقود هذا التضخم كان اموال الدعم الذي
خصصته الحكومات للحد من اثار جائه كورونا
تحولت من نعمه الى نقمه
بفهم الاسباب نعود الى نهايه اجراءات
الاغلاق بعد انحصار الجائحه رغم متحورها
وقتها عاد الاقتصاد الى النمو اسرع من
المتوقع المصانع التي جمدت الانتاج لم
تواكب ارتفاع الطلب الاقتصاد الصيني بدوره
تاثر بالسياسه صفر كوفد التي الغيت قبل
اسابيع الطلب لم تقابله وفره في الانتاج
اللي تبدا الاسعار في الارتفاع وهنا خرج
التضخم عن السيطره ليستمر في الارتفاع
بسبب الحرب الاخرانيه لكن كيف يتاثر
المواطنون
نلقي نظره اقرب
في اوروبا اولا استطلاع عنا للراي نتائجها
جاءت صادمه
93% من الاوروبيين قلقون من ارتفاع كلفه
العيش وقدرتهم على الوفاء بالتزاماتهم
الماليه والنتيجه كما تشاهدون التظاهرات
في بريطانيا وفي فرنسا الملايين خرجوا الى
الشوارع هذا الاسبوع الاسباب كثيره اساسها
اقتصادي ومنها ارتفاع اسعار الطاقه ورفع
سن التقاعد كما حدث في فرنسا اليوم اما في
امريكا اتخلف عن سداد الديون الذي حذرت
منه وزيره الخزانه سيؤدي الى ركودنا في
البلاد واسمع عالميه في العالم المواطن
الامريكي هنا سيارات تاثير تكاليف اقتراضه
سترتفع والكثير من الامريكيين سيقدون
وظائفهم في العالم العربي الاوضاع اكثر
صعوبه ثلث سكان تحت خط الفقر مئه وثلاثون
مليون شخص باللغه الارقام
يتوقع ان يرتفع هذا الرقم في 2024
نسبه بطاله قياسيه التضخم خرج عن السيطره
دول عربيه كثيره مدينه لصندوق النقد
الدولي
مفيش حد اصلا بعيد عنها ولكن في امور ابسط
من كده بكثير تسهيلات للناس نسب التضخم
انا في اعتقاد الشخصي دي ناتجه عن
الاستيراد الكبير بدون الحاجه او بدون
النظر الى قطاع التصنيع والتصدير الحلم
العربي والسوق عربي واحده ان واحد وسوف
السعوديه
رغم كل هذه الاوضاع السلبيه القادمه في
2023 و 2024 قد يكوناني اسوا حسب خبراء
الاقتصاد البدايه من اسعار الغذاء في
الدول الفقيره حياه الملايين مربوطه بصفاق
الحبوب بين روسيا واوكرانيا وعدم تجديد
الاتفاق سيرفع اسعار الغذاء الى مستوى غير
مسبوق اسعاره القمح اصلا ارتفعت من 200
دولار للطن الى 350 فيها عز ازمه كورونا
قبل ان تقفز مره اخرى الى اكثر من 450
دولار بسبب الحرب الاوكرانيه عمل اخر
اسعار الطاقه ليس الدول الفقيره فقط وانما
اوروبا ايضا الشتاء المقبل 2014 قد يكون
اسوا كما ذكرنا تامين الغاز له لن يكون
سهلا مع استنفادي مخزون الغاز الطبيعي
بحلول الربع الثاني من العام الجاري اسعار
النفط مشكله اخرى امريكا استنفذ نصف
احتياطاتها عوده الطلب الصيني ستزيد الضغط
على اسعار الطاقه وهذه النظريه يؤيدها
البنك المركزي الاوروبي هذاني الامران
سيكولان دافعا جديدا للتضخم الذي تحدثنا
عنه الحكماء لا تزالوا تصروا على رفع
اسعار الفائده لكن في المقابل ومقابل هذه
الاخبار المحبطه هناك امل انهاء حرب
اوكرانيا لكن ابتعاد الطرفين عن المفاوضات
والاصرار على مواصله القتال لايحي يعني
بالتسعيدي اكثر من التهدئه لكن حتى لو
انهيت الحرب هناك ما سيؤثر ايضا التنافس
الاقتصادي بين الصين وامريكا عاد للواجهه
الحرب التكنولوجيا باتت اكثر وضوحا السباق
نحو التكنولوجيا اشباه الموصلات
والجيل الخامس
[موسيقى]
خطرنا كبيره في سوريا منذ بدايه العام
عمليه كل يوم في الساعه بعد دقيقه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد
الى واقع الفلول الجيوب والسجون
الدوليه للتحالف والولايات المتحده خصوصا
المهم اكتملت خطره الارهاب انتقل على
المقياس الامريكي الرسمي من المرتبه
الاولى قبل عام 2001 الى الرابع وذلك
لتصفيه اكثر من 12 قيديه لداعش في السنوات
الثلاثه التي اعقبت اعلان هزيمته واكثر من
600 عنصر العام الماضي واحده في مئه
وعشرين
للتحالف فهل انتهى المشروع
هناك خريطه واعده جديده لاعاده هيكله داعش
وبيئه خصبه لتجديد خطره العالمي القاره
السمراء في الكثير من دول التي تعاني
فراغا سياسيا امنيا
اراضا والارهاب وان كان رغما عنها في 13
بلدا على الاقل يتمركزوا داعش بما يقرب من
20 فرعا في 9 منها احدثه الفروع داعش
الساحل الذي اعلن عنه في مارس الماضي وفي
موزمبيق في مايو سنخوض اكثر في الجغرافيا
بعد قليل لكن لن نخفي الاداء الابرز
لتوسيعها وهي الدعايه ولها يخصص التنظيم
عناصر حول العالم بعضهم متطوعون بقرشفون
يترجمون وينشرون رسائل على الانترنت
حضرت مقاله في صحيفه داعش الاسبوعيه اسمها
النبا على الالتحاق الى فروع افريقيا
وبالعمل الشبكي المعهود نشرت الصحيفه
تسجيلات من سوريا والعراق تهنئ المقاتلين
في القاره السمراء رسائل متعدده اللغات
والانجليزيه منها مهمه وذلك بحسب مركز
مكافحه الارهاب اثمرت مع داعش خرسان
بالتحديد
مهاجمتي الولايات المتحده وفي حرب
الاساسيه ضد طالبان وان قللت الحركه من
اثر التنظيم
اه دارين اريد
اي برنامج
الاسلاميه قادت على 98 بالمئه من اوتاره
التنظيم لا يشكل مصدر قلق لافغانستان او
تحديدا من الداخل لدول الجوار
ته غير المرئيه ربما كان يعني فيها كريمي
الافتراضيه يقابلها واقع يعيش الافغانيون
كل يوم يستغله التنظيم الفجوه بين طالبان
والافغان المتفاقمه بالفقر البطاله
والسياسات المخيبه لامال الشعب قدرته داعش
خرسان دلالاتها تتجاوز عدد الهجمات
المنافذه في افغانستان وهي من مئات نتحدث
عن اكثر من 300 هجمه منذ اتساع الحركه
للسلطه في اغسطس 2001 2020 عمليات تم في
اكثر الاماكن المحصنه امنيا قرب مقر وزاره
الخارجيه وفي الفندق الذي كان يرتده
الصينيون والاكثر شهره مشاهدينا على
الاطلاق الهجمه التي وقعت في مطار كابل
قتل على اثري العمليه فيه ثلاثه عشر من
مشاهده البحريه الامريكيه اهداف صعبه
تتجاوز مرحله استهدافي اقليه الهزاره وحتى
اماكن العباده ام حين نتحدث عن العدد فيدق
ان قوس الخطر في ارضي النشاه في سوريا
فمنذ بدايه العام اي في الاسبوعين الاوائل
من 2023 نفذ داعش هجوما كل يوم وفي سوريا
ايضا السجون قنبله موقوته تحوي جيشا
محتجزا يؤرق واشنطن والغرب ويضعهما في
معادله معقده مع قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
حارسه السجون خاصه بعد عمليه داعش في سجن
جويران او في سجن الصناعه في الحسكه قبل
عام من اليوم قتل خلالها اكثر من 100 عنصر
من قصد
بحسب الجنرال مايكل لاريك كورولا قائد
القياده المركزيه الامريكيه هناك
10,000 من قاده ومقاتلي داعش مسجونين في
سوريا وضعفهم في العراق وهناك جيل قادم
محتمل من التنظيم في مخيم الهول قوامه
25,000 طفل خطرون اداهم على المدى البعيد
تؤجل واشنطن التعامل معه ربما كي لا نقول
له لكن هناك ما هو خارج عن السيطره حتى لو
ارادت الطعاطي معه السلاح
المنفلت من الحرب التي ينغمس فيها الغرب
باسلحه حتى نفذ مخزون معظم دولها
الاستراتي بعد اخر لدعوه التنظيم لانصاره
في امر الماضي لاستغلال الانغماس الغرب في
الحرب الاوكرانيه الاسلحه
تسهل السوق السوداء الاوكرانيه المفتوحه
الامر عبرها تباع صواريخ جافل وستنجر التي
وردها الغرب الاكياب الكلام
لسه الكلام
دول هشه حدود متلاشيه فساد مستشعر مع
انقلابات عسكريه لم يجد داعش بيئه اكثر
مثاليه بعد سقوط مركزيه في الرقه السوريه
والموصل العراقيه لاعاده احياء مشروع
دولته الارهابيه هنا افريقيا 20 دوله على
الاقل تشهد نشاطا مباشرا للتنظيم اخرى
تستخدم للخدمات اللوجستيه اضافه الى حشد
الاموال والموارد
تتسع خريطه
اكثر من 20 فرعا داخل القاره السمراء
وابرزها هو تحالف الديمقراطيه تنشط في
اوغندا وانتقلت بعض الخلاياها عبر الحدود
الى
جمهوريه الكونغو حركته الشباب موزمبيقيه
او ما تعرف بانصار السنه والجماعه احدث
تحديدا الارهابيا للاستقرار في الشرق
افريقيا
على تنفيذ العديد من العمليات خاصه وسط
افريقيا فرع يصل عدد عناصر الى 1,100
يعتمد في التجنيد على السكان المحليين كما
ينشط استقطابه للشباب من تنزانيا وجزر
القمر جماعه اخرى بايعت داعش بعد انشقاقها
عن تنظيمات الاخرى كبكو حرام ان هجريه
وحركه الشباب الصوماليه وانصار الدين
والتوحيد والجهاد في غرب افريقيا ينعكس
نشاط هذه الجماعات بالنصق التصاعدي للعنف
والتفجيرات في دول الساحل نيجيريا النيجر
مالي وبوركينا فاسو وصولا الى حوض ابو
حيره تشاد كما ينعكس على الاقتتال مع
القاعده تحديدا منذ مارس العام الماضي بعد
ايام من اعلان فرنسا الانسحاب من ماءليف
تحرك داعش للسيطره على مناطق نفوذ القاعده
من شرق الاراضي الماليه على الحدود مع
النيجر لي يستحكم من بعض المناطق في
تحياتي مليكه واخرى باتجاه قوي وبالطبعه
الصومال حيث تلقى التنظيم احدث الضربات
بمصر زعيم التنظيم ابو البراء الاماني قبل
ايام بولايه بوتلاند
اضعاف ما حصل وما يمكن ان يحصل عليه داعش
في سوريا والعراق يجده في افريقيا مناجم
ذهب فحم حقول الغاز بريقوا الذهب مغرم في
مالك ثلاث اغنى دوله افريقيه بالمعدن
النفيس ترك الانسحاب الفرنسي منها فراغا
يحرس التنظيم بالتنافس مع جماعه
ولذلك عين داعش على ولاتينا وبالفعل
السيطره التنظيم وعدوه اللدود القاعده
لجماعته نصره الاسلام والمسلمين على مناطق
حدوديات يسهل تهريب المعادن عبرها
ويهجرون السكان لتسهيل لمعان الناس في
جنوب افريقيا التي يمثل المسلمون اثنين
فئه جذب التنظيم اليها خاصه في بريتوريا
لكنه اكثر الوضوحا في موزمبيق حيث ادت
الحملات الوحشيه التي شنها فرع اهل السنه
والجماعه الى مقتل اكثر من ثلاثه الاف شخص
وتشريد حوالي مليون شخص وتهديد استثمارات
الغاز بمليرات الدولارات واذا للمزيد في
هذا الملف ينظم الينا من واشنطن السفير
جيمس جفري المبعوث الامريكيه الخاص
لمحاربه داعش اذن التنظيم يجدد مشروعا
يضرب بقوه في سوريا يتمدد في افريقيا
وهناك وجود له واضح في افغانستان اذن
العمل الشبكيه قائم والاستقطاب والتجنيد
ايضا همم مستمر ماذا نتوقع في عام 2023 من
داعش وكيف
ستصدى الولايات المتحده لهذا الماده
الجديد لتنظيم داعش
اول شكرا جزيلا
الولايات المتحده تعمل
كما يقال عبر الافق للتعاطي مع تهديدات
داعش في افغانستان وحتى
في كافه الاماكن التي يوجد فيها حضور
للدوله الاسلاميه في العراق وسوريا
كان قد حقق داعش نجاح الاستثنائيا في
السنتين 2014 و2015 والولايات المتحده
قامت
بيت ارسال مجموعه كبيره من الدعم الى
بغداد من اجل ضمان التنسيق بحيث يتم العمل
بين قوات الناتو وقواتي التحالف للمساعده
في منع 11 على وجه التحديد من الانتشار في
الى مساحه اكبر في سوريا ولا ارى انه هناك
اي توجه للولايات المتحده لسحب قواتها من
سوريا
القائد المسؤول عن هذه القوات الغوريلا
الذي ورد ذكره في تقرير
عن ضروره
مواجهه 11 اينما ظهر في سوريا او العراق
ولكن ليس في المناطق التي تعد خاضعه على
السيطره المشكله الثانيه التي اراها ان
هذه الاداره
كانت قد سعت
لمحاصره داعش رغم كافه مساعيه لتوسع في
العراق وسوريا واوروبا واوروبا والولايات
المتحده واماكن الاخرى وهذا يعني ان هناك
مراقبه لتحركات داعش وهناك احاديث تجري
الان عن الجيش الثاني من داعش الذي قد
يكون وهو من اولئك الموجودين في سجون
مختلفه في سوريا والعراق اخيرا
ندرك بان هناك عشرات الاف من الاشخاص من
الاطفال والمراهقين الذين يسعد داعش الى
تجنيدهم وغسل ادمغتهم من اجل العمل بين
صفوف في سوريا سوف تبقى الولايات المتحده
معنيه ومنخرطه في هذا الامر لكن لن يكون
لنا اي مشاركه في فرنسا بعد الانسحاب
الفرنسي من هناك وهذا الامر سوف يكون
متروكا
للقيادات ونعلم ان داعش قد يقوم بعمليات
تفجيرا في موزمبيق وافريقيا ومناطقه
مختلفه هناك وهو ما يقوم به الان وايضا
يعني بالعمليات عبر الافق تمكنا التحالف
من حصد الكثير من القيادات داعش ولكن ما
تشهده سوريا الان تحديدا
والمنطقه بشكل عام العراق ايضا تشهد هجمات
لكن ما تشهد سوريا تحديدا اربع وثلاثون
عمليا لداعش في سبعه اشهر لا يغير ذلك من
استراتيجيات الولايات المتحده والتح في
مكافحه داعش
ان عدد هجمات داعش قد انخفضت والولايات
المتحده وفي الاونه الاخيره
ومن خلال المعارضه القوات المعرض التركيه
كانوا قد نجحوا في التصدي الاداعش حتى في
مناطق تقع في شمال الشرق السياسه الحاليه
سوف تعمل على ابقائي داعش
بطريقه لا يتسبب فيها في اي مخاطر في
سوريا والعراق وسوف تكون هناك قدرات
مستمره لشني ضربات على داعش
بحيث يتم دحره في مناطق تبعد عن مناطق شرق
الفرات التي يقع البعض منها تحت سيطره
النظام الامر متروك ايضا للسياسه السوء
النظام السوري اذا ما كان يرغب بان يعمل
على انهاء
المبعوثه
لمحاربه داعش
[موسيقى]
من اي مكان تتابع منه الان الساعه سته في
نهايه اليوم وبالتاكيد ستنام وفي مكان
واحد
لكن هل تتخيل انه يمكنك النوم في بلدين
مختلفين في نفس الوقت
من الان هو حتى المقبله انا حنين
[موسيقى]